Christmas in the bomb Carter Burton
Family yeah because
we have a vision of your life
from the actual so is it
yeah and then maybe the first Christmas
he decorated the tree I thought he likes
having creative control of the tree
because he's quite artistic so he did
the tree and everything which looked all
right but then as you got closer you
realize there were some zombies and dead
babies and
this is what I was just like you know
are you really there were no ones he's
obviously a sick man no didn't you
notice but he loves again his movies for
Christmas no he loves Christmas because
he in fact he went and got the lights
today